we're suppose like something that like a
student has done to you before like when
you first started man I mean endless man
I mean there are things that the Jackie
Chan one that one was the first like act
of defiance or someone who pushed back
Razzak okay this is pretty funny but
this is what I should expect you know
until I can get better yeah and for me
I'm very performance-based where it's
like I want to keep getting better I
gotta outdo my last performance but it
was it was in class and this kid was
just cutting up and she was just she had
so many opportunities and I'm sure my
the class was chaotic but she was part
like just the most chaotic and so I
don't know if I did this intentionally
or not but I was like I you're [ __ ]
out because you seem like the leader so
I got to make an example you know and
then everyone else you know fall in line
and I know if that's what I really
thought in that split second but looking
back on it I think that's what I did and
I said alright that's it like you know
student you had chances we did this you
need to go you need get out of class
yeah and just lying movingly angling
know what I don't give a [ __ ] I was like
I don't think you heard me right so I
was me thinking like I'm a thug yeah
turn to rouse I don't think you heard me
like you need to get the F or whatever I
said like out of class and she said all
right I started walking away thinking
like okay I didn't like stay face or
yeah I'm like it's an email to the
principal cuz I might be asked now gave
your yeah she said something it's like
Jackie Chan I was like turn Rollins like
did you say something what'd you say I
said Jackie Chan [ __ ] the rest
of like that class I was just known as
mr. Jackie Chan it consistently reminded
me of that incident where I failed to
act properly to de-escalate yeah you
know what to figure out like why was she
distracted all that thing and maybe she
needed a break maybe she should have you
know gone down to the principal's office
but when she came back the opportunity
to rebuild that was gone it's gone it's
gone because of the way I acted you know
and some people will say like no but
you're taking too much ownership you
know she
victimize her she should not be doing
that you're absolutely right but if I
start thinking along those lines what am
I gonna actually change I mean and their
standards right you as an adult and as
an educator you have to show restraint
right you can't get baited into like an
emotional response especially when
you're kind of aware of what the
situation is gonna be yeah but the funny
thing is too is like we're humans know
where it's not robot-man yeah yeah yeah
I never II I never restored that with
her and she was cooler so at the enemy
at the end of the year we didn't get
along you know but we like saw
eye-to-eye and we tolerated each other
but after my training I realized and
this happened after I started receiving
receiving some of those trainings that I
alluded to was I did something similar
to another student a female student in
fact and then like after that I realized
like female pushback is a trigger for me
especially when they like you know get
real like loud or they just like because
I felt you know some of my things were
being threatened but then with her you
know I I didn't cuss at her or anything
but I raised my voice I got really close
to her and then I intimidate her like is
there something you want to add no
that's what I thought yeah that's right
and like I walked away or something like
that but like everyone sees that you
know I'm like the class was quiet I had
enough like Capitol cultural and social
capital where you know they were able to
respond no one like treated me
differently but you know I felt like
[ __ ] afterwards and so I went to her
privately the next day I pulled her out
of like a different classes a that was
totally disrespectful like I can't
believe I did that and whether you
forgive me or not I'm just gonna like
commit to never doing that you ever
again in person and nobody should ever
do that to you yeah and that's it with
your permission can I apologize to you
in front of the whole class and she was
like that's a little weird
you're just gonna put me on blast oh
yeah well I I got you you know mr. Cohen
like we're cool and then but later on
she came back and said you know I talked
to my parents and said like is that the
first time an adult apologized to you is
like yeah it was like I'll have them do
it in person and see if he really means
it yeah she didn't tell me that in
person but she came back and said you
know what I actually would like it in
person so I did and I told everyone and
we had like honest conversations and
people were like yo like mr. quandary
are you serious like no one ever
apologized to her we're just kids
but that kind of like then that became
my favorite class yeah the rest of the
year you know they're doing things like
that like really humanize dismiss yeah
for sure for sure and it's holding
yourself accountable yeah yeah I'm so
[ __ ] hard cuz I'm cuz I wanted to be a
teacher I would I'd be roasting these
kids like 50% of the time that's what I
was doing that's how I build rapport
with them and they would roast me back
and I'm like damn that was funny let me
write that down I gotta talk to my
friends know that kind of thing there's
different ways to build relationships
but um yeah they when you when you asked
like what are some things that you have
seen there are things that have been
disruptive you know things that have
just appalled me or things I have just
broke my heart because I realized like
the chances of you changing your
trajectory because of like the gangs
that you're involved in or because of
you yeah it like there's only so much we
can do so there's something that's
popular called the hundred reps theory
just like you might get to like the 90th
or 99th of reps and you don't get to see
them change or like really get to that
hundred rep but you're just hoping you
planted enough seeds that it can
flourish with the next educator or the
next advocate or the next person work
but they're sure like I literally had
thank you part of me is kind of
hesitating because I don't want to like
perpetuate this stereotype of like
inner-city schools but some of it's
pretty [ __ ] funny too like I had a
male kid who ever I had a policy of I
teach belt the bill no one got to use
the restroom when they were in my class
yeah and then it's illegal to do that so
I never put it down in policy but I
would work it around so I was like oh
you got